I've never been more proud of you for
anything in your life I mean I've solved
a lot of cases for you and yet crime has
continued if we don't find something
conclusive it jeopardizes the case and
opens the department up to a lawsuit so
cancel your plans we're here until this
is over damn it Peralta ow I know
everyone's mad at Peralta for ruining
their
weekend but that was it I was just
demonstrating for detective Peralta what
a fact is can I get $350 in petty cash I
need to an ice cream party for Terry
with an eye make sure there's no hard
feelings why she gets it was a
misunderstanding she's a Terry and
you're a Terence who even though he's
not a child still goes by a nickname
ending in a why I mean don't people call
you Ray how dare you since Peralta's
briefing was cut short you can all use
this time to clean up your desks look at
this place half-eaten food crumpled
tissues pictures of your families what's
wrong with pictures if you love someone
you'll remember what they look
like what is this rubber band ball keep
your bands in a box or a bag since you
all apparently have time to play throw
I'm canceling overtime for the month
effective immediately get to work and
deall these bands just that you can be a
bit judgmental what a stupid thing to
say name one time when I've been
judgmental okay what the stupid thing to
say oh I see it should take 70 seconds
for you to fully gauge someone's
character here's what to look for
grammar posture scent attire level of
perspiration type of shirt collar what's
the best type of shirt collar English
spread obviously but let's hold the
questions until the end when people say
good morning they mean Hello when people
say how are you they mean Hello when
people say what's up they mean I am a
person not worth talking to there are
two acceptable sleep positions on back
toes up arms crossed or on back toes up
arms at the side do not trust any child
that choose bubble gum flavored bubble
gum do not trust any adult that choose
gum at all never vacation in
B I'm off to walk my Beat Again much
like Copus condemned to push the the
same boulder up the same Hill day in and
day out you know according to French
philosopher Alber Camu Copus achieved
happiness in that absurd repetition any
French philosophy post Russo is
essentially a
magazine you
Ru Lieutenant as you know I've been
walking the same beat for the past 3
weeks it's become a bit tedious I
thought you love tedium I love monotony
they're very different I'm sorry but you
know our policy is that uniformed
officers must walk the same beat for 6
months that's how they become familiar
with the community they serve well
surely you can make an exception for me
I can't play favorites you never did
when you were in charge of course I did
really I never got any special treatment
I think you can do the math here damn
Captain hey you really thought this was
going to work uh it did work this whole
janitor Gambit was designed to fail it's
just like in chess sometimes in order to
win you have to sacrifice your king
that's exactly how you lose a
chess hey Captain I just sent you an
email you're captain we were all so
sorry for your loss please let us know
if there's anything we can do sent from
my stinky butt I was hacked thank you
for the email it means a lot to me
you're very welcome I was addressing
your stinky butt marriage is a contract
between two adults of different
families it's a Hau and a fact it works
on two levels maybe I should Wing It
Love it sustains you it's
like oatmeal okay okay not bad for
winging it I lied took me 2 hours to
write that bad moon I'm sorry have I not
been bursting in a song enough for you
lately would you like me to click my
heels together or skip like a school
child yes to all of that but for reals
What nonme thing is bothering you is the
trouble at home we're all done I'm not
going to discuss my home life with you
we're not friends we're not family
you're not my my husband that's hurtful
I thought we had a special bond I was
your Secret Santa last year and I
already thanked you for the ho farted
baseball cap well done but I do have to
ask those guys at the impound do they
really smash my car no in fact I had
them wash
it good one Captain you can't wash a car
so how'd you convince the whole Squad to
betray me what did you offer them I
asked them if they wanted to embarrass
you and they instantly said yes not
going to lie that turns me on a little
bit this is what I have so far
[Music]
pain that's it and now for a message of
Hope ah a message of Hope right on time
everything is garbage oh no you find
something you care about it's taken from
you your colleague your dream
job your mango
yogurt
never
love
anything that's the
lesson to Captain dozerman Captain do I
work on my speech how's this for an
opening
joke you know what the toughest part
about being a gay black police officer
is the
Discrimination I believe that's what you
call observational humor so meeting
Amy's dad for the first time huh you
nervous yeah a little I was talking to
Jake no sorry I am not nervous I'm
confident that I'll make a great first
impression on Mr Victor Santiago why'
you do with a British accent I feel like
doing the Cuban accent be a little dicey
for me very good call yeah my advice
don't be overc confident the first time
I met Kevin's parents I called brahs
fanga Opus
106 when it is obviously Opus 104 they
haven't spoken to me since really just
for that yes also because of huge
homophobes who think that I made Kevin
gay with my magic genitalia can Terrier
is intelligent and inquis to do with a
bold personality a bold personality we
know what that's code for she's a
and this beautiful handcrafted card of a
turkey wearing a top hat it's a
Pilgrim's hat where's the Buckle
Santiago do you want a president who
struggled Against All Odds to create
this great organization or do you want a
great nothing who struggled against
nothing odds to create nothing Dez
congratulations on moving on to the
second round said I sarcastically the
only thing you won last Heist was a
lifetime of medoc heterosexual
intercourse with Jake guys this Fanboy
stuff is a little much the only thing
that's a little much around here are
your scrawled on eyebrows yes it's
clearly zumas and that's a good thing
you can finally say goodbye to your
Nemesis thanks Sergeant that's a nice
thought for an idiot to have I don't
know why you're telling me I'm not
involved you made that very
clear come here Diaz how'd you know it
was me the restrained knock everyone
else in his office plays my door like
it's a marima the other day today
Jeffers gave it three Taps and two wraps
was he drunk one can only assume
Microsoft Word is not a special skill
Marcy Lux from South Orange just know
you have
disappointed all three of
us ooh fun Terry's playing the flute at
work who are you William Wonka you're
not hell you looking for Al of course
we're looking for Al you imbecile let's
do this you are so easily manipulated
now you're stuck with Sergeant dumb Dum
I can't wait to eat your
food oh it is revolting what's your
story behind a
PB&J I want a sandwich I make a sandwich
I eat the
sandwich